Okay, danke.
Guten Tag.
Schönen guten Tag.
Ich bin auch dieses Jahr aus Ostens-Asthetik.
Würde ich mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschrag hören?
Sind Sie von der Frechheit zustande?
Ja, gerne.
Ich möchte Ihre wichtige Frage gestalten.
Wie heißen Sie?
Schmidt Thorsten.
Mit DT.
Schmidt Schmid Schule.
Thorsten.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen und Ihren Vornamen bestalten?
Ja, gerne.
S-C-H-M-I-D-T-T-H-O-R-S-T-E-N.
O-R-S-T-E-N.
Genau, Thorsten.
Thorsten ist meine Vornahme und Schmidt ist Nachname.
Thorsten.
Ja, genau.
Thorsten ist mein Vorname.
Herr Schmid.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 50 Jahre alt.
50.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,80.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
90 kg.
Was haben Sie mit den Schweden?
Herr Schmid, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, eine gute Frage.
Davon bin ich hier.
Ich hoffe, dass Sie mich auch helfen können.
Ich habe in der letzten Zeit stark Kraftlosigkeit,
Schlappheit.
Ich bin schnell erschöpft,
wenn ich nach 100 m bin.
Ich habe keine Kraft mehr.
Die sind Probleme, die ich in der letzten Zeit habe.
Seit wann haben diese Beschwerden?
Die sind nicht auf einmal aufgetreten.
Die sind langsam.
Und in der letzten Zeit ist es zu nehmen.
Da würde ich sagen, 4 Wochen.
Sind bei Ihnen,
gibt es doch andere Beschwerden.
Ich habe aber kurz nicht verstanden.
Können Sie bitte wiederholen?
Es gibt doch bei Ihnen
die endischen Beschwerden oder andere Beschwerden.
Diese Ersalte Beschwerden begleitet.
Ob ich noch nebenbei parallel andere Beschwerden habe?
Das ist Ihre Frage.
Wie ist es,
dass Sie Kraft und Schlapplosigkeit erschöpft haben?
Schlapplosigkeit habe ich nicht erwähnt.
Aber so eine Kraftlosigkeit ist so,
wenn ich einen Tripper steige,
zum Beispiel nach 2.Tage, bin ich schon erschöpft.
Dann fühle ich mich müde.
Ich fühle mich schlapp.
Ich muss sitzen,
ein bisschen Pause haben.
Und nach 15 Minuten
kann ich dann noch weiter 2.Tage gehen.
So sind es.
Nach 200 Metern, wenn ich gerade laufe,
muss ich auch Pause haben.
Sie müssen Pause haben.
Aber wir können Beschwerden
oder eine Schmerz haben.
Ich habe keine Kraft mehr.
Herr Schmid,
kann uns um die Ersalte
in der Zeit zu sprechen?
Ab oder zu gönnen?
Eine gute Frage.
Ich habe keine Kraft mehr.
Herr Schmid,
eine gute Frage.
Ich habe schon etwas abgenommen.
Ich habe keine Waage zu Hause.
Aber ich gehe davon aus,
dass ich ungefähr so 3-4 kg abgenommen habe.
Wie ist die Arbeit?
Es war irgendwie unverändert.
Haben Sie Kopfschmessen?
Ja, wenn ich müde bin,
habe ich leicht einen Kopfschmessen-Druckgefühl.
Aber so dauerhaft Kopfschmessen
würde ich nicht sagen.
Ich habe keine dauerhaft.
Ab und zu.
Ja, genau.
War das unter Fieber?
Ob ich Fieber hatte?
War Ihre Frage?
Ich habe es nicht gemessen.
Nein, ich habe nicht Fieber gehabt.
Ich habe auch nicht eine warme Gefühle gehabt.
Weil du es unter Schweißausbrücke
oder nach Schweiß?
Ich habe es unter Nachschweiß.
Nein, aber vor allem wenn ich mich belaste,
oder warend
ich habe es nicht gemessen.
Aber während
laufen
dann im dem Zeitpunkt habe ich
ein bisschen Schweißausbruch.
Da sind am meisten
Unterbelastungen.
Genau.
Haben Sie Herzrasen?
Ja, das habe ich auch.
Aber Ruhe nicht nur beim Belastung.
Wie fühlen Sie
so große Herzrasen?
Wie klingt das?
Wie fühle ich den Herzrasen?
Wie sind Ihre Fragen?
Das ist normal.
Als das Herz rauskommt
und schlägt schnell.
Manchmal so unregelmäßig.
Manchmal ist es schnell.
Ich spüre es einfach.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Ja, wenn ich mich belaste,
habe ich auch Atemnot.
Ruhe? Nein.
Wenn ich hinlege,
dann ist das alles im Grundbereich.
Keine.
Haben Sie irgendwelche
Verdammt-System-Probleme?
Zum Beispiel eine Verstoffung
oder Abtür zu haben?
Was wollen Sie mit Abfußung haben?
Zum Beispiel...
Ob ich eine Abfußmaßnahme durchgeführt habe?
Ja.
Gegen Verstoffung.
Ich habe wieder Verstoffung,
noch Durchfall gehabt.
Was ich gemerkt habe in der letzten Woche,
so leicht zu einem schwarzen Stuhlgang habe ich gesehen.
Aber aus einer richtigen Verstoffung habe ich nicht mehr.
Einmal, oder?
Ein paar Mal habe ich gesehen.
Leider unter Durchfall?
Oder in der Zeit,
habe ich es nicht mehr erwähnt.
Ich habe wieder Durchfall,
noch Verstoffung.
Ich habe keine Durchfall und keine Verstoffung, das heißt.
Haben Sie Bauchschmerzen?
Bauchschmerzen?
Die Hälfte ist ein Schmerzen.
So leicht über Bauchschmerzen,
ist es ein Schmerz.
Aber es ist nicht so stark.
Bauchschmerzen?
Nicht so stark?
Ja, es ist ein bisschen ein Objektivesache.
Ich kann das nicht machen.
Wie sagt man die Schmerzen?
Wobei,
keine Schmerzen sehen.
Sehr stärker und perfekt.
Wie würden Sie
welche Stufe
einigen?
Meine Schmerzen,
die ich einstuchen kann,
wenn ich Schmerzentage habe,
ab und zu, bis es zwischen 7 bis 8.
Aber ansonsten nehme ich so etwas ein,
als Sie gesagt haben,
die sind auch seit ungefähr 2 Wochen,
vorher hatte ich das auch nicht gehabt.
Ab und zu leicht schmerzen,
war auch ja, ich kann das nicht verneinen.
Welche Zeitraum
diese Schmerzattacken
auftreten?
Die treten am meisten
spontan.
Ich habe es nicht darauf geachtet,
wann am meisten der Attacke sind.
Ich bekomme das auf einen nach sofort
und dann nehme ich etwas ein und gehe weg.
Können Sie?
Was meint Sie mit dem Zeitraum?
Was sollte ich denn achten?
Zum Beispiel
wie die Schmerzattacken
in welcher Zeitraum
lange anhalt?
Oder fühlen Sie sich
zum Beispiel krankfertig, rückend, stehend?
Welche Art sind die Schmerzen,
meinen Sie?
die sind die Schmerzen?
Welche Schmerzen hatte ich?
Manchmal sind die Stiche in der Form,
aber sind die eher rückend Schmerzen.
Ist das kollekartig?
Nein, ich habe nicht mehr den Kollekartig.
Haben Sie Erwürfel oder
übergeben?
Ob ich mich übergeben habe,
über.
Ob ihr Urbel ist.
Überigkeit,
ja 1, 2 Mal,
aber aber auch nicht so stark.
Ich habe da keine Medikamente
eingenommen.
Sind bei Ihnen nicht schwierig?
Ja, schon.
Ja, schon. Wenn ich schnell aufstehe, in der letzten Zeit ist mir getragen etwas schlecht und dann habe ich schwindel und versuche langsam, langsam aufzustehen.
Haben Sie auch Ihrem Stuhl oder Wasserlassen Ungewöhnliches oder Auffälliges bemerkt?
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich in der letzten Zeit eine schwarze Schulgang habe, 3-4 Mal gesehen.
Beim Wasserlassen habe ich gar kein Problem, muss ich sagen.
Von dieser schwarzen Stunde gesehen?
Ich freu mich, dass ich das gesehen habe. Das war gestern zum Beispiel, habe ich gesehen.
Gestern?
Ja genau.
Haben Sie ein katholästiges Beispiel oder Rotenfäbiges erbrechen?
Ich habe nie erbrochen.
Ja, ich habe nie.
Herr Schmidt, wo ist eine Operation?
Ich habe eine Operation gehabt. Ich habe zum Beispiel Blindarm OP gehabt. Das war ungefähr vor 20 Jahren.
Vor 20 Jahren?
Genau.
Geht es noch bei Ihnen eine wissenschaftliche oder chronische Erkrankung?
Nein, ich leide unter keine chronische Erkrankung.
Wie muss ich Ihnen vorstellen, wenn ich mich auf die Kommentare komme?
Nein, ich nehme keine Medikamente aus, der Schmerzmittel ab und zu.
Ansonsten habe ich das Beispiel auch nicht gebraucht.
Haben Sie eine allergie gegen Besten-Pilates-Medikamenten?
Nein, das ist auch mir nicht bekannt.
Sind Ihre Impfungen vollständig?
Welche Impfungen meinen Sie?
Ich bin vollgeimpft oder gebustet.
Herr Schmidt, brauchen Sie?
Ja.
Wie viel seit wann?
Seit 20 Jahren ungefähr, seit 20 Jahren.
Ich habe mich auf die Kommentare geholfen.
Wie viel seit wann?
Seit 20 Jahren ungefähr, so ein 20 Stück pro Tag.
Sie kennen Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ab und zu.
Welche Alkohol?
So ein Bier, manchmal so ein Schnaps auch.
Ja.
Arbeiten Sie?
Ich bin arbeitslos jetzt.
Haben Sie unter Stress?
Ob ich viele Stress habe.
Ja, wenn man arbeitslos ist, hat man doch auch Stress.
Das ist normal.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche oder auch gedrohen?
Ne, habe ich nie gedrohen.
Nehmen Sie aktuell Riemen oder Probenen?
Nehmen Sie eigentlich nur die Probenen.
Ob ich vorher Drogen zu sich genommen habe oder probiert habe, habe ich nie gehabt.
Genau, alles klar.
Das freut mich.
Danke schön.
In Ihrer Familie auch noch wissenschaftliche oder chronische oder erfahrene Krankheiten von Ihren interessanten Sofen?
Ich habe keine Geschwister.
Meine Eltern sind noch am Leben und die sind auch kein gesund, muss ich sagen.
Nur meine Mutter, ja meine Eltern leben noch.
Meine Mutter ist 70 Jahre alt und die hat nur leicht Blutdurchdruck und nimmt so ein, zwei, drei Medikamente hinter.
Und sonst leidet unter keinem anderen Erkrankungen.
Ja, Vater?
Die hat Diabetes und der nimmt einfach so eine Blutzuckermedikamente, um so weit ich weiß.
Er spritzt sich keiner in die Linie.
Mindestens hat es nie gebraucht bisher.
Genau, alles klar.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie sind Arbolstlost und
wie ist Ihr familiales Stand?
Ich bin lelig.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, habe ich keine Kinder.
Ich habe eine Freundin und wir haben uns auch getrennt vor einem Monat.
Leben Sie mit Freunden?
Nein, bin ich jetzt alleine.
Haben Sie Tiere?
Zuhause habe ich keine.
Ich würde von Ihrem Beschwördern zurückkehren, Herr Schmidt.
Ihr Bachschmerzen, auch ein Gefahren Essen oder Recht und Televensmittel?
Ich habe, als ich gesagt habe, ich habe es nicht darauf geachtet, woran lebt das oder wann am meisten auftreten.
Die kommen wie Attacca einfach und gehen wieder weg, wenn ich den Schmessmittel eingenommen habe und daher so ein genaues Zeitraum oder Ursache zu bekannt geben können, das habe ich nicht geachtet.
Alles klar.
Ich bin mit einem Nase fertig.
Was haben Sie mit dem Nase?
Ich will einfach wissen, was ich habe oder was Sie für mich machen können.
Ich muss ja dem, ob ich jetzt, wie Sie denn in der Notaufnahme, ob Sie mich stationär aufnehmen müssen oder ambulant behandeln sollen.
Das will ich keine wissen, damit ich auch meine Familie mit teilnehmen kann.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, Ihr Beschwördern sind lebensbetruglich sein.
Und ich möchte Ihnen im Krankenhaus aufnehmen.
Hier könnt ihr auch sagen, ich würde Sie gerne stationär aufnehmen.
Vielleicht ist es einfach nicht im Krankenhaus, aber ich würde Sie gerne stationär aufnehmen.
Stationäre aufnehmen.
Genau, da ist das.
Dann, nach Ihren Analyse oder Ihren Beschwördern, Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben eine Rote gemüsscht,
und in den Wochen, um eine Möglichkeit und Schlegung und Erschöpfung zu haben.
Und auch dergleichende andere Beschwördern, deuten am Hersten auf eine Nagel-Folutung,
aber diese nur eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Erstmal muss ich Ihnen Präferlition untersuchen.
Dann werde ich Ihnen natürlich eine geblendete Verfahren und Blutlabodiatmostik veranlassen.
Nach diesem Labodiatmostik kann ich sicher Ihre Beschwörde zu Ihren erklären.
Okay, sehr gut.
Okay, das heißt, ich bleibe jetzt in der Notaufnahme und Sie werden zu paar Untersuchende schweren.
Und dann werden Sie mich auch stationär aufnehmen, damit ich genau wissen, was ich habe.
Ich verstehe.
Ich habe es wiederholt.
Ich habe gesagt, Sie werden mich jetzt stationär aufnehmen, dann heißt es, ich bleibe erst in der Notaufnahme.
Sie führen zu paar Untersuchende durch und dann der Rest wird auf Station durchgeführt,
so damit ich am Ende mitbekommen kann, was ich habe oder wie ich das umgehen damit.
Okay, dann...
In der Notaufnahme leiten wir an bestimmten Regen der Medikamente ein und eine zum Beispiel eine Özer und eine Zubankregel.
Dann andere Behandlungen und bisgebänden Erfahrungen und alle Labos zu suchen, auf stationäre Kontrollieren.
Okay, das heißt in der Notaufnahme bekomme ich so ein paar Envisionen,
weil so eine Vinoza meistens schwierig zu verstehen.
So soll man einfach anders ein bisschen formulieren.
Sie können auch so sagen, Sie bekommen von mir so ein paar Medikamente als Envisionen oder Patroff.
Patroff, das heißt das ist über Vinoza, so im Alltag Deutsch sagt, so ein paar Troff oder als Envisionen.
Wenn Sie Vinoza sagen, wird das nicht ankommen, genau, das heißt es ist Vinoza.
Ingeln werden?
Ja, aber im Alltag man versteht das nicht.
Sie können auch sagen, Sie bekommen von mir so eine Visionen oder Medikamente, Patroff, nicht Troppenso-Patroff,
das heißt, was Trofft, was wehen und geht rein.
So formuliert am meisten im Alltag?
Ja, genau.
Aber es ist okay, wenn Sie auch Vinoza sagen, vielleicht mit der Prüfung geht das auch.
Okay, jetzt, ist es gut, haben wir alles gefragt, wenn wir im Grunde jetzt fragen, war das genug,
der Anamnese, oder sollen wir noch etwas vertiefen?
Wir fragen im Grunde jetzt, alle Kollegen, die da sind jetzt.
Ja, ich habe eine Frage, leiden Sie unter Schluckstörungen?
Gute Frage. Nicht so stark, etwas schon.
Okay, was meinen Sie?
Jetzt auch gute Frage.
Jetzt sollen Sie jetzt mich fragen, was heißt denn Schluckstörung für Sie?
Sonst Sie mir jetzt genau formulieren, wenn Sie Flüssigkeit fingen oder wenn Sie Nahrung zu sich nehmen,
wie das klingt, dann sollen Sie es auch fragen, weil das kann die passieren auch nicht genau wissen.
Sie unterschließen, sollen Sie dann fragen.
Ja, Flüssigkeit und Nahrung oder Festnahrung?
Haben Sie Probleme mit normalen Festnahrung oder mit Flüssigkeit?
Mit Festnahrung habe ich Probleme, mit Flüssigkeit habe ich kein Problem.
Noch, Sodbrinninn ist auch gefragt worden, ja, leicht auch, habe ich auch.
Vor allem, wenn ich mich hinlege, dann habe ich mich mit Sodbrinninn gefühlt.
Haben Sie sonst noch etwas Ungewöhnliches bemerkt, zum Beispiel Gelbsuch?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Noch, in einem Nase könnte man schon etwas vertiefen, zum Beispiel Alkoholgeschichte.
Wir sind einfach so schnell rübergeklärt, haben gesagt, ich trinke ab und zu,
das soll man ein bisschen vertiefen, wie heißt ab und zu und wie viel?
Da soll man auch fragen, wenn man sagt, ich trinke einfach so Bier,
muss man fragen, wie viel davon?
Und das ist auch wichtig zu wissen, weil in Deutschland ist es Bier,
es ist ein normales Nahrungsaufnahme, das ist eine Standortennahrung.
Daher, die Sillen sind nicht als Alkohol getrinkt.
Das soll man auch vertiefen noch, haben wir etwas vergessen?
Wir können auch fragen, Eisen-Tablette.
Genau, die Kollegin hat general gefragt, ob ich eine Tabletteinnehme.
Da habe ich auch general beantwortet, dass ich Außenschmerzmittel gar nichts einnehme.
Daher, aber ich habe recht, dass wir auch fragen.
Wir können auch fragen, wie heißt die Schmerz-Tablette?
Genau, ich nehme eine Walgien und noch.
Nur bei Bedarf?
Ja, nur bei Bedarf, nehme ich ein, zwei Tabletten manchmal, nicht so viel.
Okay, jetzt sind wir durch damit.
Atamnot ist auch gefragt worden, hat die Kollegin schon gefragt.
Ich habe es beantwortet, dass ich keine habe.
Außer wenn ich mich belaste, das war es anders.
Ansonsten habe ich keine Probleme.
Dann haben wir alles gefragt, jetzt gehen wir zur Arztgespräch.
Ja.
Okay, dann.
Hallo Herr Oberarzt.
Hallo, schönen guten Tag.
Haben Sie seitdem ich?
Sehr gerne, darüber bin ich hier.
Ich habe in der Nothoffnahme einen Patienten unterstützt.
Und ich möchte Ihnen diesen Patienten vorstellen.
Ja.
Herr Thorsten Schmidt, 40 Jahre Patient, 1,80 kg.
Ich habe keine Kinder.
Und ich bin arbeitlos.
Er hat keine Kinder, okay?
Er hat keine Kinder.
Er kommt mit seit vier Wochen eine Möglichkeit
und Erschlägenheit und Kraftlosigkeit.
Wie kann man das anders formulieren?
Er kommt zu uns mit Müdigkeit, Schlappheit.
Seit vier Wochen bestehende.
Bestehende.
Oder er stellt sich mit der Müdigkeit, Schlappheit und Kraftlosigkeit.
So kann man auch formulieren. Das klingt besser.
Beides nicht schlecht, aber mit bestehenden Problemen.
Er kommt zu uns mit bestehenden, seit vier Wochen.
Müdigkeit, Schlappheit und Kraftlosigkeit.
Und vorgestern auch getretende Milena.
Seit gestern, nicht vorgestern, aber vorgestern, hat er einmal Milena gehabt.
Oder seit gestern hat er Milena gemerkt.
Eine von die Beides.
Und das ist eine, die uns auch mit Milena geholfen hat.
Und auf Nachfrage zum Beispiel nausea und verdank problem, dyspepsie und Fieber,
Achschweiß und Hustern, Disple oder Verneint.
Ausseldern fügt dahin so eine Schwindel, Vertigo beim Aufstehen und diese Befunde schiebt für eine Anämie.
Welche Art von Anämie anhand der Anämie?
Seit vier Wochen beste Hände, Abgestellwandheit und Grafossikkeit.
Welche Art von Anämie könnte das sein?
Welche Art von Anämie ist es?